presque évenou cette journée
d'aujourd'hui elle s'annonce comme la
mobilisation des villes moyennes est-ce
que ça vous inquiète cette colère qui
vient des villes moyennes aucune
manifestation ne doit être inquiétée en
revanche elle doit être entendue l'enjeu
aujourd'hui des manifestations c'est que
c'est bien évidemment le lieu ben
légitime de revendications et ses
revendications nous devons être en
capacité de les entendre mais plus que
de les entendre dans débattre au sein de
l'émission et c'est ce que nous
demandeons notamment en tant que
parlementaire puisqu'effectivement le
temps parlementaire et aujourd'hui là
alors il se termine demain soir à minuit
mais nous ne désespérons pas et nous
espérons qu'enfin et bien ces
revendications soient débattue au sein
de l'Assemblée nationale et on va venir
évidemment sur le débat à l'Assemblée
très rapidement sur la mobilisation
mobilisation des villes moyennes
aujourd'hui mais mobilisations qui
s'annoncent moindres que les précédentes
il y a un essoufflement du mouvement je
pense pas qu'il y ait des soufflements
du tout d'ailleurs je voudrais vraiment
remercier très chaleureusement les
macronistes et prises qui a été venaux
en particulier parce que plus vous
saturez les plateaux plus vous
développez votre argumentaire plus les
Français
cette réforme et d'ailleurs un sondage
publié ce matin par l'Ifop montre que
72% des Français rejettent cette réforme
donc il n'y a pas d'essoufflement du
tout il y a un mouvement social qui est
aujourd'hui très soutenu massivement
soutenu par la population et la
caractéristique effectivement de ce
mouvement social c'est qu'il s'encre
dans les territoires il est évidemment
puissant dans les grandes métropoles
mais il est aussi très puissant dans les
petites villes et dans les villes
moyennes et donc ce que je vois surtout
c'est qu'on a un mouvement qui s'encre
dans la durée il y a la journée
d'aujourd'hui il y aura le 7 mars avec
la France à l'arrêt le 7 mars si le
gouvernement n’entend pas cette
mobilisation mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que ce mouvement il est
puissant et il est parti pour durer tant
que le gouvernement fera la sourde
oreille
moi j'entends ce sujet cette phrase
qu'on entend à longueur de journée dans
dans l'hémicycle mais moi ce que je suis
en train de dire c'est une question de
entendre pas entendre c'est en réalité
que faites-vous moi ce que je me ce dont
je me rends compte c'est que on a face à
nous la nuit Pesse qui représente
aujourd'hui et je le dis très clairement
une arnaque politique au sens propre du
terme c'est-à-dire qu'ils nous font
croire en long en large en travers qu'on
pourra avec le défi démocratique qu'on a
non seulement poursuivre sur ce système
de répartition sans le réformer mais en
plus baisser l'âge de retraite à 60 ans
qui nous explique qu'il veut en
permanence travailler pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français mais dès qu'on a le
dos tourné dans l'hémicycle et bien ils
essaient d'augmenter les impôts pour
tous d'ailleurs vous vous essayez pas
vous le faites à Paris et ensuite on a
aussi ce sujet où il représente la voix
des travailleurs et en fait que font-ils
quand les syndicats leur demandent de
pousser un index au Seigneur ils disent
attendez cher ami on va voter contre
parce que ça nous fait bien marrer donc
aujourd'hui je préfère le dire nous ne
sommes pas là simplement pour nous pour
nous parler entre nous mais pour parler
des besoins des Français mais surtout
les respecter c'est vous passez votre
temps à répéter ça et à répéter vos
éléments de langage je le redis depuis
un mois et les Français vous détestent
les Français haïssent cette réforme les
Français ne supportent plus votre
arrogance et votre mépris et
contrairement à ce que vous dites ça
n'est pas une affaire de nup contre le
gouvernement ça n'est pas sale sujet
c'est la France contre le gouvernement
c'est la France du travail ce sont ces
millions de travailleurs qui se
mobilisent et parfois ceux qui ne
sortent pas dans la rue mais qui
rejettent cette réforme qui aujourd'hui
ne veulent pas de ce que vous êtes en
train de mettre en place et vous dites
il faut écouter les Français qui
manifestent c'est quand même
extraordinaire manifestement vous avez
un problème d'audition parce que ce que
disent les Français c'est qu'ils ne
veulent pas de la retraite à 64 ans
c'est ça qui aujourd'hui motive les gens
à sortir dans la rue et dans le même
temps on a une première ministre et un
gouvernement qui dit il n'est pas
question de toucher à cette affaire des
64 ans donc vous vous moquez du monde
vous ne pouvez pas dire d'un côté il
faut écouter les Français qui rejettent
cette réforme il faut écouter les
Français qui se mobilisent et dire dans
le même temps il n'est pas question de
débattre de la question des 64 ans parce
que c'est le cœur de la mobilisation
bien sûr que si puisque la première
ministre a dit c'est non négociable
alors peut-être que vous n'écoutez pas
non plus peut-être que vous n'écoutez
pas la première ministre mais en
l'occurrence c'est ce qu'elle a dit
ça n'est pas négociable et donc la oui
mais vous soutenez ce gouvernement ou
alors on a un scoop sur ce plateau et
vous ne soutenez ni le gouvernement ni
la réforme des retraites mais à ce que
j'ai pris j'ai compris madame Thévenot
vous passez votre temps à être la
porte-parole du gouvernement et je crois
que vous êtes même la porte-parole de
renaissance donc en l'occurrence oui
assumez la politique du gouvernement
vous ne voulez pas débattre de cette
question des 64 ans mais enfin si c'est
le cas vous tant mieux
la France souffre le martyre à cause de
vous et la France du travail est en
train de vous dire qu'elle ne veut pas
qu'on sentir à des efforts
supplémentaires parce que dans le même
temps effectivement et je l'assume il y
a des gens qui se gavent et auxquels
vous ne demandez pas le moindre effort
déjà je pense que je me permets un parce
que avec ce qu'on vient en ce moment
dans l'hémicycle je préfère vous dire
taxer de mépris je pense que c'est
l'argument qu'on a plus d'arguments et
nous dire que les Français nous
détestent en réalité quand quand et
ensuite dire monsieur je vais finir
monsieur j'ai fini je vous ai vous ai
parlé tranquillement et ensuite me dire
qu'il nous déteste je pense que ça
n'apporte rien au départ non on déteste
pas les gens on combat des idées ensuite
je veux le dire aussi simplement
parler effectivement débattre du sujet
de l'âge mais écoutez oui il y a une
réforme qui a été présentée qui a été
présentée au moment même des élections
présidentielles se faire de ma part
d'ailleurs vous étiez porte-parole des
élections présidentielles nous avons
affiché cette réforme maintenant nous
voulons pouvoir nous en tant que
parlementaire élu en débattre au sein de
l'hémicycle et je vous l'ai dit très
clairement pendant 10 jours dans
l'hémicycle mais aussi pendant trois
jours et trois nuits en commission la
nupesse est uniquement la nupesse nous a
dit nous ne voulons pas débattre
allons-y ayez ce courage politique
d'assumer ce débat opposer vos arguments
plutôt que de nous dire que nous sommes
méprisants détestables ou je ne sais
quoi encore qui n'apporte rien aux
Français et bien allons-y des bâtons moi
ce que je vois et je le dis de façon
très claire hier soir entre 22h et
minuit on a vu dans l'hémicycle
effectivement un certain nombre
d'amendements tombés de la nupesse
j'espère et je le dis très clairement
que c'est de bonne augures pour la tenue
des débats d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
que nous allons sûrement pouvoir aller
sur l'article 7 sur les 64 ans il y aura
les Français se fichent totalement de la
procédure parlementaire on peut débattre
pendant des heures du débat lui-même
mais tout ça n'a aucun sens aucun
intérêt ça n'est pas ça qui intéresse
les Français la question que se pose
l'article sauf que la question que se
pose les Français elle est elle est
extrêmement simple extrêmement claire
est-ce qu'on va devoir travailler deux
années supplémentaires est-ce qu'on va
demander à des assistantes maternelles à
des Carreleurs à des ouvriers à des
employés de travailler deux années
supplémentaires C'est ça la vraie
question c'est ça le cœur du sujet et
donc on peut débattre en permanence de
l'attitude de telle ou tel et d'ailleurs
vous avez aussi votre part de
responsabilité dans la décrépitude du
débat démocratique oui je le dis ça veut
dire par exemple que quand Bruno Fuchs
kiffe appartient à votre majorité qui
est député du MoDem donc de votre
majorité se permet de comparer ceux qui
s'opposent à la réforme des retraites
aux assassins de Samuel Paty c'est une
ignominie c'est une ignominie acceptée
il faudrait aussi regarder ce qui se
passe dans un certain nombre de la
macronie ce qui m'intéresse et ceux qui
m'intéresse c'est le cœur du débat c'est
le cœur du sujet est-ce qu'on oblige les
Français à travailler davantage où
est-ce qu'on cherche d'autres pistes de
financement pour nous retraite et donc
c'est une vraie question de société vous
savez quand on a mis en place la
retraite par répartition à l'issue de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale avec Ambroise
Croizat qui était ouvrier et qui a mis
en place ça lorsqu'il était ministre on
n'a pas commencé par se demander combien
ça coûte on a commencé par se dire c'est
nécessaire pour redresser le pays et
ensuite on a trouvé les financements
nécessaires pour y arriver d'abord le
projet de société d'abord la vision
comporte et ensuite on trouve les
sources de financement aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans la même situation et donc on
doit se placer à cette hauteur là de
débat et c'est ce que je souhaite faire
évidemment à la France avec de retirer
encore plus d'amendements pour arriver
plus vite les parlementaires communistes
ce sont toujours comportés comme ça je
vous parlais de 1945 mais c'est le cas
aussi aujourd'hui et André Chasset une
autre président de groupe à l'Assemblée
et profondément fidèle à cette tradition
là et donc pour ce qui nous concerne
nous nous sommes par définition
responsable de ce que nous faisons
nous-mêmes nous continuerons à avoir
cette attitude là qui est une attitude à
la fois très combative et très
responsable parce qu'on peut dire des
choses très fortes et très radicales en
étant calme serein mais déterminé
presque vous avez intérêt arrive à
l'article 7 vous ne craignez pas d'être
mis en minorité tout le monde y a
intérêt tout le monde y a intérêt et
j'entends tout à fait ce que vous dites
effectivement mais expliquer ça à vos
collègues vos partenaires de la lsfi
notamment puisque moi je le dis aussi
très clairement il faut dire les choses
ELV aussi a commencé à retirer ses
amendements ils ont pas attendu hier ils
ont commencé à le faire en début de
semaine donc encore une fois il s'agit
pas simplement de pointer du doigt pour
pointer du doigt mais pour dire entrons
dans le débat maintenant le débat de
fond c'est ce que j'entends c'est
trouvons d'autres moyens de financement
pour notre système de retraite et donc
là je le redis encore une fois donc
assumons que dans ce débat on peut
considérer qu'on sort du système par
répartition parce que trouver pas trop
moyen de financement c'est aussi dire la
réalité aux Français dire nous sortons
du système où ce sont les salariés
actuels les actifs actuels qui cotisent
pour les pensions actuelles nous allons
en trouver d'autres et donc nous sortons
de ce système pareil partition et vous
savez très bien ce que ça pose derrière
c'est potentiellement la fragilité du
système ça il faut être aussi capable de
le dire puisque vous citez de grands
hommes il faut aller au bout de leurs
propos
le débat il est justement opposé vous
vous nous dites si on ne fait pas
travailler les Français plus longtemps
on remet en cause le système de retraite
par répartition mais pas du tout comment
est financé notre système il est financé
grâce au cotisations sociales et ces
dernières années les gouvernements
successifs pas seulement le vôtre
d'ailleurs mais les gouvernements
précédents ont passé leur temps d’abord
à ne plus parler de cotisations sociales
mais à parler de charges sociales et à
les réduire et donc à fragiliser le
financement de nos retraites c'est
d'ailleurs une grande hypocrisie on vide
les caisses et ensuite on s'étonne
qu'elle ne soit pas pleine et donc ce
que nous disons nous c'est qu'il faut
remettre de l'argent dans les caisses de
retraite comment par exemple
en augmentant les salaires aujourd'hui
vous avez une inflation qui est
importante vous avez une baisse de
pouvoir d'achat pour ceux qui
travaillent et donc ce que nous
suggérons nous Fabien Roussel a
d'ailleurs déposé une proposition de loi
en ce sens c'est d'indexer les salaires
sur l'inflation si vous augmentez les
salaires de 7%, vous faites rentrer 12
milliards d'euros dans les caisses de
retraite mais non mais ne soufflez pas
vous savez
mince non seulement on a du mal en ce
moment en inflation mais
augmenter les salaires est-ce que je
peux juste terminer est-ce que je peux
juste terminer mon raisonnement
oui il faut augmenter les salaires et
oui bien sûr il faut aider les petites
entreprises et quand je vois que chaque
année l'état vertes 160 milliards
d'euros d'être public sans conditions
aux entreprises y compris de très
grosses entreprises qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale jeudi concentrons
nos aides sur les petites entreprises ça
leur permettra d'augmenter les salaires
et ça permettra de faire rentrer de
l'argent dans nos caisses de retraite au
moins le débat est posé on dit les
choses et ça nous permet d'avancer sur
un débat
après très rapidement vous le savez très
bien qu'on peut pas décider comme ça de
façon arbitraire pour le privé de dire
chers amis augmenter les salaires 99
plus de 99% de notre tissu français ce
sont des TPE PME des entreprises où il y
a même pas un salarié en général donc ce
que je vous dis c'est qu'en période
d'inflation dans laquelle nous sommes en
ce moment on va leur dire les amis
allez-y non seulement c'est compliqué
mais en plus on vous oblige à augmenter
l'ensemble de vos salariés sans aucune
sans aucun regard sur votre situation
économique ce n'est pas entendable
aujourd'hui ensuite vous nous dites oui
mais on a baissé l'imposition sur les
entreprises et c'est un drame absolu
mais non c'est pas un drame absolu parce
que en parallèle ça permet de créer plus
d'un virgule 6 millions d'emplois et je
vous le dis et je vous le dis tout de
suite
changez pas de sujet c'est le cœur du
sujet je vous parle de grosses
entreprises attendez j'ai fini mon
propos ça vous dérange mais je vais le
finir sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
parlons franchement l'impôt sur cft oui
le taux d'imposition a baissé passer à
25 % et vous trouvez jamais nous n'avons
reçu autant de recettes de la part de
cette impôts x 2 en 1 an ça vous parle
donc en réalité ça sert à rien de savoir
la solution de la facilité c'est imposer
imposer imposé sauf qu'avec cette
solution le sujet c'est pas augmenter
les salaires mais sans trouver on va
parler d'un thème dont il est beaucoup
question ces dernières heures dans
l'hémics il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations de parlementaires c'est
sur la question de la retraite minimum à
85% du SMIC à 1200 euros Audrey d'abord
on va essayer de voir un peu plus clair
avec vous j'espère que tout le monde est
bien accroché parce que ce n'est pas
simple les calculs sont très compliqués
les situations différentes ça il faut le
concéder au ministre mais peut-être que
les calculs ils avaient pas vraiment été
fait vous allez voir pourquoi 25 janvier
dernier le ministre est auditionné au
Sénat question de la sénatrice
écologiste Mélanie Vogel question donc
combien de retraités toucheront vraiment
la pension ion à 1200 euros je vous
propose d'écouter la réponse du ministre
sur les 1200 euros je ne sais pas le
dire précisément je sais que le système
que nous proposons permet de revaloriser
la pension et la petite pension d'une
certaine manière de 200 000 nouveaux
assurés par an c'est-à-dire un départ
sur 4 le ministre ne sait pas il le
concept mais il donne un autre chiffre
les pensions revalorisées des nouveaux
retraités oui mais voilà les
parlementaires veulent savoir on lui
repose donc la question à l'Assemblée
c'était il y a deux jours réponse en
deux temps attendez un peu et puis on va
finalement je vous donne des chiffres
je languis moi aussi de pouvoir vous
apporter ses réponses et je les
apporterai à l'article 10 je suis allé
retraite pays imam ce sont plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
chaque année
bénéficieront cette garantie à 1200
euros à qu'il en bénéficiait pas
aujourd'hui bon finalement la réponse
est arrivée hier matin après on
l'imagine quelques calculs en urgence de
la part de ses services écoutés
on a une prévision elle m'est arrivée
hier soir 40
000 personnes de plus chaque année
passeront le cap des 85% du SMIC grâce à
cette seule
réforme donc chaque année 40 000
nouvelles personnes en environ partiront
à la retraite avec à peu près 1200 euros
sur cette question de la part du
gouvernement non je me permets
simplement de rappeler dans quel
contexte effectivement beaucoup de
collègues de la nu pour ont interrogé le
ministre sur cette question en long en
largeant travers se servant d'amendement
qui n'avait rien à voir avec le sujet
nous étions en train de parler de
l'index senior l'index senior qui est
justement demandé par beaucoup de
syndicats et notamment qui représentent
les travailleurs donc c'est vrai que le
SMIC et nous-même l'ensemble des autres
parlementaires disions mais parlons du
sujet de fond et traitons sujet après
sujet donc c'est pas qu'il a essayé de
pas répondre c'est juste que c'était pas
le sujet du débat et je pense que c'est
aussi important de respecter l'ordre du
jour d'un débat ensuite sur le sujet des
pensions revalorisées bien évidemment
que c'est important parce que c'est une
grande mesure
nous allons avoir sur l'ensemble des
revalorisations 1,8 millions de français
actuellement retraités impactés dont
effectivement on va avoir 250 000 qui
supplémentaires qui auront cette
revalorisation qui va dépasser ou
atteindre les 85% du SMIC pour une pour
une retraite complète et ensuite ça sera
40 000 euros à peu près par an ce qui
est important de souligner aussi c'est
que deux tiers de ces personnes de ces
bénéficiaires de ces relevalorisations
seront des femmes donc oui nous devons
pouvoir donner ces chiffres oui nous les
donnons mais il n'y a aucune volonté de
ne pas les donner il y a juste une
volonté de respecter les articles que
nous sommes en temps débattre c'est
aussi simple que ça excusez-moi mais
votre petit montage il est tragique il
est tragique il est tragique à la fois
pour le ministre et il est tragique pour
les Français parce que affolant d'avoir
des gens qui nous expliquent qu'ils ont
préparé cette réforme dès la campagne
présidentielle et qui plusieurs mois
après la campagne présidentielle ne sont
même pas capables de donner un certain
nombre de chiffres sur une promesse qui
pourtant a été claironnée sur tous les
toits et puis quand même
début on nous a dit ça concernera tout
le monde au début on nous a dit ça
concernera un million 800 000 personnes
et aujourd'hui on nous dit ça concernera
40 000 personnes vous savez il y a eu ce
film quand j'étais petit qui s'appelait
chéri j'ai rétréci les gosses et là
maintenant c'est chérie j'ai rétréci la
promesse c'est à dire que en réalité ça
exactement
ça ne concerne que que 5% des futurs
retraités
partez du principe que les gens qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec vous sont aussi
intelligents vous vous gagnerez du temps
je pense au contraire que vous les
Français ont je fais partie des gens non
mais là
partez du principe que c'est le cas ce
sera plus simple et vous verrez ça nous
permettra de débattre tout le monde
dégage la réalité c'est que les Français
ont très bien compris l'arnaque pas
seulement sur ça surtout les sujets
surtout les sujets pareils ils ont aussi
compris que ce serait ils ont aussi
compris que ce serait madame thévenois à
qui voulez-vous faire croire que vous
n'avez pas
mentiellement vous avez été pris tout
cela en flagrant délit de mensonges vous
avez été pris en flagrants
maintenant que vous avez été cohérente
sur le sujet vous savez le seul qui a
dit la vérité c'est Franck Riester
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
qui a admis que cette promesse des 1200
euros de la pension minimale était en
réalité quelque chose qui n'existait pas
et quelque chose qu'on a vendu aux
Français qui va être jeunes français et
qui ne correspond pas la réalité
ce qui est lunaire c'est votre manière
de gouverner en vous moquant des
Français et on vous cueillant leur tête
en permanence en termes de moquerie je
vais vous le dire tranquillement certes
vous n'êtes pas parlementaire mais vous
êtes quand même élu élus dans une
majorité qui s'appelle celle de la faute
mais en termes de mensonges je n'ai
aucune leçon à recevoir dessus alors je
vous le dis tranquillement maintenant je
le redis les revalorisations de pension
vont concerner oui vous avez le bon
chiffre mais pas dans le bon ordre 1,8
millions de Français à l'aventure à 1200
euros ça concernera combien de personnes
bien sûr 250 comme vous en avez donné
des différents
combien de personnes qui seront
revalorisés la retraite à 1200 euros
c'est combien de personnes vous avez vu
ce qui se passe c'est très symptomatique
c'est que c'est la même démarche la même
technique c'est-à-dire que même dans
l'hémicycle quand on essaie de parler
quand on essaie on ne peut pas alors
soit de temps en temps on s’agace et on
explique qu'il faut qu'on puisse parler
aussi c'est la même chose sur les
plateaux donc je le redis
des oblige en fait je le redis de façon
très claire 1,8 millions de Français à
la retraite actuellement auront une
revalorisation des pensions de l'ordre
de 55 euros par mois c'est pas rien
monsieur c'est 6% d'augmentation il y
aura exactement
250 000 personnes supplémentaires qui
verront leur retraite dépasser ou
atteindre les fameux 85% du SMIC et
ensuite pour les nouveaux entrants dans
notre système de retraite ça sera 40 000
par an supplémentaires oui ça vous
paraît ça vous paraît insolent mais je
vous le dis très honnêtement ce qu'on
est en train de faire vous avez jamais
fait vous ne l'avez jamais fait donc au
lieu de tourner en rond aujourd'hui
peut-être regarder un peu ce qui permet
aujourd'hui d'améliorer le sort de nos
pensions les plus après car on va pas
vous mettre d'accord là dessus on a
compris on va parler d'un article qui a
été voté il y en a pas eu beaucoup mais
il y en a eu sur la fin progressive des
régimes spéciaux parmi les concernés les
salariés des industries électriques et
gazières Jérôme Rabier est allé à Lyon
les rencontrer en regard
bienvenue ici nous sommes à l'union
locale CGT de Vénissieux Saint-Fons
Feyzin où les syndicats dans toutes les
catégories professionnelles s'organisent
pour lutter ensemble ici les militants
CGT sont évidemment opposés à la réforme
des retraites mais ce qui inquiète
davantage mot de milliers c'est la fin
du régime spécial dans les industries
électriques et gazières car avec la
réforme les agents de ces entreprises
héritières d'edfgdf vont voir le statut
disparaître pour les futurs embauchés
puisque aujourd'hui nous sommes un
régime particulier qui existe depuis
tout temps qu'il y a notre statut qui
est lié à nos missions de service public
et aujourd'hui c'est lui qui est en
danger dans la réforme qui est présentée
par le gouvernement et en perspective de
la prochaine loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale la fin d'un statut créé
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale et qui
pour la CGT va créer des entreprises à
plusieurs vitesses il est pas acceptable
que sur un même site de travail ou dans
une la même entreprise cohabitent deux
contrats de travail différents deux
statuts différents et de régimes de
retraite différents c'est opposer les
salariés les uns aux autres ceux qui ont
pu perdre sont les salariés dit du
service actif qui ont des missions
pénibles ou nécessitent une
disponibilité totale ce sont notamment
eux qui doivent maintenir le réseau
électrique en cas d'intempéries Antonio
Noguerra est un de ses agents pour la
société enedis et pour lui la pénibilité
à une définition bien réelle et c'est
aussi bien travaillé à genoux sous 2
mètres sous le sol ou les mains en l'air
à 10 mètres en l'air que ça soit sous de
la neige coulante du vent du canicule et
ça a tout au long du jour de la nuit il
y a un n'importe quelle heure à titre
personnel il a fait ses calculs et la
réforme aura un impact bien concret dans
la réforme je partirai à 60 ans
mais avec la réforme je devrais partir à
64 ans nous on aura une double peine
deux ans supplémentaire pour tous et
comme moi j'effectue des tâches pénibles
et contraignantes je vais je vais perdre
le pénibilités et donc du coup deux ans
supplémentaires encore et ça fait 4 ans
en plus une réforme qui selon lui va
fragiliser l'attractivité dans ses
entreprises et qui explique la
mobilisation importante dans ce secteur
auprès de 60% des salariés ont participé
au précédentes journées d'action pour
des enfants qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à ces inquiétudes mais j'entends tout à
fait ces inquiétudes mais je veux dire à
ce monsieur que déjà premièrement ceux
qui sont déjà embauchés employés
salariés ne seront pas concernés si à la
fameuse clause du grand-père donc seule
les nous devons entrants et ensuite je
lui ai envie de lui dire mais non en
fait justement c'est mieux prendre en
compte les pénibilités mais accepter que
dans une même entreprise la j'entendais
enedis et ben tous ne pouvons pas sujets
à la même pénibilité ce monsieur a un
travail extrêmement pénible extrêmement
douloureux physiquement il ne pourra pas
continuer jusqu'à 64 ans il devra
pouvoir partir avant les autres mais pas
tout le monde au sein des nudistes a le
même travail que lui et donc c'est ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous pouvons nous devons
regarder être plus proche de ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin et ça il faut avoir
la responsabilité politique de le dire
aujourd'hui et nous devons pouvoir
débattre précisément au cas par cas des
enjeux de pénibilité alors visiblement
je crois pas que ça va pouvoir arriver
au sein de l'hémicycle parce que là ça
traîne encore une fois voyons et
j'espère que j'aurai tort sur ce point
là mais je rassure ce monsieur non il
faut pouvoir prendre en compte sa
pénibilité et ça fait partie de la
réforme
qui est un discours classique fort
répandu qui consiste à présenter un
certain nombre d'agents de nos services
publics comme des privilégiés à
expliquer qu'ils auraient des acquis qui
auraient vocation à être remis en cause
et supprimé d'abord ce que je vois c'est
que dans ces entreprises je pense
notamment à la RATP par exemple il y a
énormément de difficultés à recruter et
donc si c'était des métiers dans
lesquels avait des acquis sociaux
absolument extraordinaires et si ces
gens étaient des privilégiés ce ne
serait pas si dur de recruter c'est donc
que ce sont des métiers qui sont
difficiles qui sont pénibles et c'est ce
qui explique le manque d'attractivité de
ces métiers et la réalité surtout c'est
qu'en supprimant ces acquis sociaux là
on va rendre ces métiers encore moins
attractifs mais vous le savez je pense
que la justice le combat pour l'égalité
celui qui m'anime comme communiste ça
n'est pas d'enlever à ceux qui ont un
peu le peu qu'ils ont c'est de lutter
contre les vrais injustices quand je
vois par exemple monsieur pouyanet qui a
un salaire de 500 000 euros par mois
nous expliquer dans Le Parisien il y a
quelques jours que la justice c'est de
faire travailler davantage ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui au charbon je trouve ça
honteux et donc je pense que dans notre
pays si on veut s'attaquer contre les
injustices et contre les inégalités
c'est pas assez salarié là qu'il faut
s'attaquer pour conclure il reste deux
jours de débats à l'Assemblée puisque
demain à minuit le texte va partir au
Sénas que vous pensez que l'examen pour
aller jusqu'au bout parce qu'il y a
tellement
pas jusqu'au bout du texte soyons très
clair
euh la démarche que en train
d'entreprendre la nuque et à mon avis un
peu trop tard mais maintenant j'espère
qu'on pourra quand même aller jusqu'à ce
fameux article 7 l'article sur l'âge
parce que c'est un débat qui a attendu
pas pour nous simplement en tant que
parlementaire mais pour les Français
donc voyons ce qui arrive ça se trouve
là je vais arriver dans l'hémicycle et
je vais me rendre compte qu'il y a
encore des milliers d'amendements qui
sont tombés et tant mieux ça ne dénature
pas la qualité des débats mais ça nous
permet d'aller plus précisément dans les
débats
ce que nous souhaitons nous surtout
c'est que cette réforme soit retirée
parce qu'elle ne correspond pas du tout
à l'aspiration des Français et si le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas la retirer
il est libre de la présenter sous forme
de référendum aux Françaises qui
permettra au peuple de trancher cette
question de manière tout à fait
démocratique merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat vous
restez avec nous quelques instants si
[Musique]